- I am not registered to vote.
- I am registered to vote
but I probably will not be
voting this upcoming election.
(patriotic music)
- The whole process is
intimidating and confusing
and I just don't really
know where to begin.
- I don't think my vote's
going to make a difference.
The candidates that we've had here,
I haven't been passionate
about any of them.
- It's very time consuming.
There is a huge line.
(dramatic music)
Oh wow!
Okay, metal detectors.
- There's serious security at this.
There's like a man with a machine gun
- Dip your hand in purple ink
and you pretty much vote
with your fingerprint
- People are threatening these women,
saying if they vote,
they're going to come to their houses
and attack them.
- Risking your life to go vote
I mean, it's pretty brave.
- The ink that they get on their finger,
that's not just like an I voted sticker
that you can take off.
It's gonna be there for
the rest of the day.
So it makes them a target for people
who are trying to harm them
and that's really scary.
- I had no idea it was so dangerous
to do something this simple
(gentle music)
(gasp)
- It's so exciting to see a lot of people
show up to vote who
fought so hard to do so.
- They were talking about the numbers of
how many African Americans versus
how many white people had
gone to the polls to vote
and they said 80% of
the people in that area
had gone who were African American
so that is incredible considering how
there's so many of us today who say
I'm not voting.
(inspiring music)
- Wow.
- Some of the men talking
in this, oh my God.
So these women aren't
allowed to leave the house
without a male chaperone.
Oh well if she leaves the house to go vote
who's going to take care of the children?
How long is it going to take
for her to leave the house
and go vote?
(lips smack) Sit down.
- At least they're standing up
for something that they believe in.
- These women are still
going out and voting
even though there's still
so many borders in their way
There's not really a border in my way.
I'm just lazy.
(gentle music)
- She's talking about Saving Private Ryan.
- And how, in China, people
found it kind of strange
the notion of saving one person
by risking the lives of six other people.
She relates that to voting.
So, kind of saying that
your vote doesn't matter
it's almost saying that, you know,
one life doesn't really matter.
- Me being Cuban and, you know, my parents
are from a communist country,
voting is not a thing.
- This World War II veteran
had never missed voting
and on his deathbed, he votes.
Yeah, okay, way to make me feel bad.
(upbeat music)
Watching these videos
kind of made me realize
the contrast between
how I feel about voting
and how a lot of other
people feel about voting.
- I feel like the voting
process in America
is actually pretty simple.
- Vote because you have the right to.
Vote because you feel like
it's your civil liberty to
and vote because it's
the right thing to do.
- It's really opened my mind.
It makes me feel like an (bleep). (laughs)
- I got some thinking to do.
- Yeah, I want to register to vote.
Yeah (laughs)
Let me get my email.
(laptop shuts)
That was (bleep) easy. (laughs)